Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und mit beständiger Regelmäßigkeit veröffentlichen wir hier neue Gespräche, so auch heute eine weitere Reise in Teilaspekte des Gesamtuniversums Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik. Und nachdem wir in den ersten Folgen schon viel auch ja, die Erde verlassen haben über Planeten deriert haben, sind wir in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen auf dem Weg zurück auf den Boden der Tatsachen, der ja bei dieser ganzen Problematik auch eine nicht zu verachtende Rolle spielt, denn die paar Astronauten, die da oben im Orbit ihre Arbeit verrichten, das ist immer das eine. Aber unterstützt wird all das von einem her, von Forschern, Technikern, Ingenieuren, die eben durch zahlreiche Maßnahmen das Ganze überhaupt erst möglich machen. Und heute soll ein ganz spezieller Aspekt dieser Arbeit am Boden im Mittelpunkt stehen. Und zwar, man könnte sagen, der Informatiker-Bereich. Wir wollen reden über Software. Software im Dienste der Luft- und Raumfahrtforschung. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner heute Andreas, Andreas Schreiber. Hallo. Du bist Software-Techniker, ja, triffst das ganz gut?
Studiert habe ich Technomatematik, also Mathematik mit Informatik und Ingenieurwissenschaften, aber inzwischen bin ich in einer Gruppe, die nur Software-Technik macht.
Und das Ganze machst du für den DLR am Standort Köln?
Standort Köln, genau.
Was ist da dein zugeordnetes Institut eigentlich?
Wir heißen insgesamt Simulations- und Software-Technik.
Simulations- und Software-Technik. Da merkt man schon, worum es geht. Also es geht jetzt hier ganz konkret um, also es ist jetzt nicht Systemadministration im einigen Sinne, sondern hier geht es ganz konkret um den Einsatz von Software, um einfach Forschungsziele zu erreichen.
Genau. Und wir haben mit dem eigentlichen Betrieb von IT-Systemen auch nicht viel zu tun. Wir machen und bedecken den Bereich Forschung im Bereich Software ab für das DLR. Forschung und Entwicklung. Wir entwickeln selber Software, wir entwickeln Software-Technologien und wir helfen anderen Software zu entwickeln. Also da kommt das Thema Software Engineering ins Spiel, wo wir ein bisschen beraten und Vorgaben machen fürs DLR und neue Sachen ausprobieren und gucken, was der externe Markt so bietet im Bereich Software-Entwicklung und Software-Engineering.
Wie groß ist das Institut?
Relativ klein fürs DLR, insgesamt etwa 30 Mitarbeiter. Und das Ganze ist aufgeteilt in zwei Abteilungen. Wir haben aber die Abteilung verteilte Systeme und Komponenten-Software, das ist meine Abteilung. Da gehört dann auch das Thema Software-Engineering ein. Da gibt es eine Parallelabteilung für Raumfahrtsysteme und Visualisierung.
Wie Raumfahrtsysteme und Visualisierung und dein Bereich verteilte Systeme und Komponenten-Software. Wie immer im informatischen Bereich blumige, wolkige Bezeichnungen, um irgendwas zu fassen, was sich ja schwer fassen lässt eigentlich. Und für wie viele Leute betrifft eure Tätigkeit? Also ihr habt ja gesagt, ihr entwickelt selber, aber ihr helft ja auch zu entwickeln. Das heißt, ihr seid auch institutsübergreifend tätig?
Ja genau. Also Zielgruppe von uns ist das ganze restliche DLR, beziehungsweise vor allem alle Forschungsinstitute. Wir arbeiten nicht so sehr für und mit der Verwaltung, also eher für die verschiedenen Ingenieurwissenschaftlichen Institute.
Das heißt, ihr seid auch viel unterwegs?
Ja genau. Wir sind auch deswegen zum Beispiel auch in drei Standorten vertreten. Also wir haben eine Hinterlassung in Köln-Ports, da ist auch unser Einrichtungsleiter und ich sitze selber den größten Teil meiner Zeit da. Dann haben wir noch, ein Großteil unserer Leute sitzt in Braunschweig und ein paar Leute sitzen noch hier in Berlin-Adlershof.
Genau, hier in Berlin. Jetzt haben wir uns nämlich hier mal außerhalb deiner Primärzone getroffen, sozusagen, weil eben auch gerade da jetzt auch im Einsatz warst. Was umfasst dann so eine Tätigkeit, wenn du da auf Reisen bist? Also was...
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Also jetzt bei dieser Reise ist es halt so, gestern war ich in einem anderen Ort in Göttingen, hab mich dort mit einer Universität mit Leuten getroffen, die jetzt so mögliche Zusammenarbeiten im Bereich Softwareforschung.
Zusammenarbeiten mit Universitäten, also auch mit dem Forschungsarm, sozusagen jenseits des DLR.
Ja, genau. Und heute bin ich zum einen ja natürlich hier bei dir und dann nachher habe ich noch ein Mitarbeitergespräch, weil ich auch Abteilungsleiter bin. Da kriegt ein Mitarbeiter dann seine Leistungsbewertung, so wie er das letzte Jahr über gewesen ist, und dann besprechen wir, wie das jetzt im nächsten Jahr weitergeht.
Weil jetzt so konkret mit Software-Engineering in dem Sinne hat das jetzt so erstmal nichts zu tun. Das heißt, es bewegt sich sozusagen auch so ein bisschen auf der Metaebene, dass man über Forschung als solche spricht?
Ja, das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also auf viele Reisen, die sind sehr fachspezifisch natürlich. In der Regel kann man sagen, dass es immer unterschiedlich ist. Und nie das Gleiche.
Das heißt, ihr seid eigentlich ein relativ kleines Institut, habt aber große Auswirkungen, weil ihr eigentlich mit nahezu allen Forschungsinstituten in Verbindung steht.
In der Praxis sind es noch nicht alle, das ist natürlich unser Ziel. Also, dass wir Softwarelösungen bereitstellen oder andere Leute beraten in Softwarelösungen in allen Bereichen des DLR. In der Praxis ist das im Moment noch ein bisschen weniger, ich würde sagen, die Hälfte der Institute. Mit denen arbeiten wir irgendwie in Projekten zusammen, in DLR-internen Projekten oder beraten die in irgendeiner Weise. Beispiele sind aber auch zum Beispiel, dass Kollegen aus meiner Gruppe vor Ort sitzen in den Instituten und dort mitarbeiten. Also ein Kollege ist in Braunschweig, in einem anderen Institut, hat dort sein Büro und entwickelt dort einen Strömungslöser mit. Und ein anderer Kollege ist hier in Berlin vor Ort, in einem anderen Institut für Verkehrsforschung in dem Fall, und macht dort in einem Projekt so was wie Testmanagement und Testen.
Das heißt, euer Institut ist ein bisschen so ein generisches Institut, wo es um die Disziplinen als solche geht und dann im Feld findet, dass dann seine konkrete Anwendung im Kontext der Forschung eines anderen Instituts ist.
Genau, das ist so eine klassische Querschnittsaufgabe, ähnliche Qualitäts- und Produktsicherung und ähnliche Themen. Und dann eben stark mit Fokus auf Software und Software Engineering.
Das heißt, ihr versteht wahrscheinlich dann das auch ganz stark als Dienstleistung auch?
Teilweise. Also der Bereich Software Engineering, wo wir andere Leute beraten, das geht stark in Richtung Dienstleistung. Wo wir Software Engineering-Methodiken erarbeiten und die dann anderen Leuten erklären oder helfen, die einzuführen. Das hat starken Dienstleistungscharakter. Der große Rest ist aber auch Forschung. Und wir sind auch eine richtige Forschungseinrichtung des DLR. Also keine Dienstleistungsgruppe. Und wir haben auch eine ganze Reihe von Forschungsprojekten mit hauptsächlich externen Partnern. So EU-Projekte und Projekte vom Forschungsministerium und so weiter.
Woran forscht man dann? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt Software, ist leicht gesagt, weites Feld, betrifft ja im Prinzip alles, was Computer betrifft. Und Computer betreffen natürlich alles, weil wahrscheinlich heutzutage kein einziger Forscher mehr ohne arbeitet. Das heißt wahrscheinlich, das ist so. Nun kennt jeder Software so ein bisschen als etwas, das mal mehr oder weniger gut funktioniert. Jetzt sind natürlich die Anforderungen hier im Forschungsbereich auf der einen Seite und natürlich dann auch im konkreten Einsatz im All nicht gerade gering. Ist das sozusagen auch ein Teil eurer Forschung zur Qualität, was umfasst das? Vielleicht kannst du mal ein bisschen beschreiben. Du hast ja gesagt, es gibt zwei Abteilungen, Raumfahrtsystem und Visualisierung. Das ist jetzt nicht genau dein Fall. Verteilte Systeme, Komponenzsoftware. Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen?
Also zum einen ist in meiner Abteilung der Bereich Software Engineering vertreten. Und wo wir uns gerade aktuell auch mit beschäftigen ist, wie man zum Beispiel den Bereich Anforderungsanalyse besser gestalten kann. Das ist eigentlich der erste Schritt in jeder Entwicklung. Ob eigentlich Hardware oder Software ist egal.
Also herausfinden, was man braucht.
Herausfinden, was man braucht. Die Anforderungen ermitteln und dokumentieren und in späteren Phasen der Entwicklung dann auch nachvollziehen. Diese Phasen sind im DLR sehr unterschiedlich ausgeprägt einfach. Wir forschen gerade im DLR nach Gründen dafür, also warum das so unterschiedlich eingesetzt wird. Und unser Ziel ist sozusagen, Möglichkeiten für das DLR zu ergründen, wie es besser gemacht werden könnte. Und zwar in der Form, dass es genau für die Kollegen im DLR auch passt. Also wenn ich irgendeine ganz tolle Lösung, die vielleicht für manche Industrien oder so geeignet ist, einfach übernehmen. Weil wir denken, dass das für die Zielgruppe, die wir bedienen müssen im DLR, also Wissenschaftler, Ingenieure, Physiker und so weiter, dass die dann damit überfordert werden und keine Lust haben. Weil die sollen ja immer noch ihre Freiheit haben, im Grunde ein bisschen ja irgendwie vorzubreschen, möglichst schnell ihre Lösung zu realisieren, wozu dann oft die Entwicklung einer Software auch gehört.
Lass uns vielleicht mal aus dem konkreten Beispiel kommen, weil das natürlich im Software-Thema, da kann man sich schnell verlieren, wenn man immer nur auf der allgemeinen Ebene bleibt. Wer tritt so an euch heran? Wie unterstützt ihr die Hinblick auf diese Anforderungsanalyse?
Also Anforderungsanalyse ist ein großes Problem, das ist zum Beispiel im DLR, das sind Studenten. Die fangen oft einfach an zu programmieren, machen sich überhaupt keine Gedanken darüber, was dann überhaupt rauskommen soll.
Also Studenten im Rahmen als Praktikumsmitarbeiter?
Genau, Praktikum oder Masterarbeit oder Bachelorarbeit oder irgendwas schreiben. Die schreiben so ein bisschen allgemein auf, was sie machen sollen und legen dann aber erst mal gleich los mit Programmieren, ohne sich Gedanken zu machen, wie die Software überhaupt am Ende aussehen muss oder welche Anforderungen da überhaupt reinspielen. Natürlich ist klar schon, was die hinterher können soll. Das ist ja irgendwie auch hinterlegt, in irgendwelchen Literaturstudien und ähnliches. Aber zum Bereich Anforderungsanalyse gehört ja ein weites Feld. Da gehört ja rein zum Beispiel auch, in welche Umgebung soll die Software eingesetzt werden, die genauen Randbedingungen, wie sie laufen muss, Performance-Anforderungen, ähnliches. Eine ganze Reihe von Sachen. Und auch Anforderungen, die dann z.B. auch die Software-Architektur betreffen. Also, wenn man jetzt... Die Software kann man ja auf ganz verschiedene Arten bauen. Komponenten orientiert oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Techniken. Und da muss man sich vorher schon im Grunde klar sein, was eigentlich das geeignete ist. Und das, wenn man einfach loslegt und losprogrammiert, weil der Kommiliton das vielleicht auch so macht, dann geht das vielleicht eine Zeit lang gut, aber nicht langfristig. Das wird dann schwierig, wenn man dann merkt, die Software soll wirklich eingesetzt werden. Und das hat man in einer Liste der Anforderungen für diese Software nicht bedacht.
Die Software tut, was sie soll, aber es hat nie einer erwartet, dass sie auch benutzt wird.
Die tut auf dem lokalen Laptop, was sie soll, aber wenn es dann mal auf dem großen Rechner läuft, dann eben nicht mehr zum Beispiel. Oder es ist dann halt nicht performant auf anderen Plattformen zum Beispiel, weil es nur auf eine Art von Rechner getestet wurde einfach. Und diese Anforderungen zu sammeln und zu dokumentieren, das ist ein Schritt, der oft weggelassen wird. Oder manche machen das auch noch, das ist wieder ein anderer Fall, da schreibt man sich was auf. Auch ganz unterschiedlich, manche nehmen so ein Whiteboard, wie du es ja auch im Büro hier hängen hast. Oder ein Zettel, also Pen und Paper, ist sozusagen eine ganz häufig verwendete Möglichkeit für Anforderungsanalyse. Aber das ist zum Beispiel schon so ein Ding, diese Anforderungen kann man dann hinterher nicht mehr verwenden. Also die kann man nicht nachvollziehen, wenn man ein weiteres Schritt in der Softwareentwicklung ist. Also wenn man Schritte weiter ist, dann ist es schwierig, da noch mal drauf zu gucken. Also wenn zum Beispiel der Zettel weg ist, wo man das mal aufgeschrieben hatte, oder wenn man die gedruckte Dokumentation, die ein Student mal erstellt hat oder anderer Mitarbeiter, wenn die irgendwie nicht mehr auffindbar ist, dann kann man das nicht so richtig nachvollziehen und kann hinterher auch schwer verstehen, warum das Software so entwickelt wurde, wie sie entwickelt wurde. Und wenn man das auch verändern will, ist das auch ein Problem. Also dann würde man ja eigentlich hingehen und sagen, man geht noch mal einen Schritt zurück, passt die Anforderung noch mal an und macht dann die entsprechende Änderung in der Software. Aber wenn man die ursprüngliche Anforderung gar nicht mehr hat, wenn man sie nicht elektronisch verfügbar und ändervar verfügbar hat, dann ist das sehr schwierig.
Das heißt, ihr habt auch dafür formale Software?
Ja, genau.
Die ihr dann selber auch entwickelt habt? Oder gibt es da Software aus dem Regal?
Das gibt Software aus dem Regal. Was wäre das zum Beispiel? Also Anforderungsanalyse, sprich Requirements Engineering, gibt es kommerzielle Software, DORS zum Beispiel oder Requisite Pro. Aber es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von freien und open source Tools, die man verwenden kann. Also sehr viele Issue Tracker oder Bug Tracking Systeme, die kann man dafür verwenden, wo man die Anforderungen einträgt und wo man sie auch schön nachvollziehen kann. Viele Leute nutzen immer noch Excel oder auch Word-Documente oder irgendwelche Datenbanken für Requalities-Analyse.
Und seid ihr damit auch glücklich, wenn das so? Hauptsache elektronisch gespeichert schon mal.
Hauptsache elektronisch kann man sich darüber streiten. Der Kollege, der sich damit hauptberuflich beschäftigt, der wird vielleicht auch was anderes sagen. Aber das Ziel ist schon, dass wir eine Lösung bieten, die im Sinne des Software-Engineering vernünftig ist. Also, dass man das alles elektronisch hat, möglicherweise über ein webbasiertes Ischow-Tracking-System, das nachvollzieht, aber die auch keinen großen Overhead bedeutet. Weil viele, auch gerade kommerzielle Produkte, die haben einen hohen Einarbeitungsaufwand zum Beispiel. Und das ist ein Kriterium, es gibt natürlich Firmen und so, wo das kein großes Problem ist, wenn die Mitarbeiter lange geschult und arbeiten sich da ein. Da ist es teilweise auch sehr wichtig, dass man sich in so ein Tool einarbeitet und das ganz genau macht. Aber im wissenschaftlichen Bereich ist es eher so, das sind ja, ich nenne es mal Software-Entwickler, die eigentlich gar nicht Software entwickeln wollen. Das ist ja nur Mittel zum Zweck, um irgendein anderes Ziel zu erreichen.
Eigentlich sind sie Forscher.
Ja, eigentlich Forscher in einem anderen Gebiet, also sozusagen Ingenieurwissenschaften oder Physik oder ähnliches. Medizin, was das heißt.
Die können dann so programmieren, wie man halt auch schreiben kann.
Ja, genau.
Und man benutzt das dann so weit, wie man kann. Aber es ist für einen dann hilfreich, das strukturierter zu machen. Aber ich kenne das auch, man macht sich dann eben ab einem bestimmten Punkt auch nicht mehr so die Gedanken, weil man dann einfach so sehr, ja, auf das Thema fokussiert ist und darüber ja auch eigentlich nachdenken will. Das heißt in dem Moment, wo ich das Gefühl habe, oha, das könnte jetzt eine etwas komplexere Aufgabe sein, das ist jetzt hier kein 20-Zeiten-Skript, was ich niederschreibe, sondern das ist eine Software, die im schlimmsten Fall auch noch von anderen Leuten benutzt wird. Beziehungsweise die absehbare Lifetime hat, die hier vielleicht auch sogar meine eigene Präsenz im Unternehmen übersteigt. Dann wäre es quasi geraten, sich mit euch in Verbindung zu setzen und zu sagen, so hier, ihr habt doch Plan von Software-Engineering im Sinne von so die Wissenschaft, wie man es macht. Was könnt ihr mir für Werkzeuge bereitstellen und was könnt ihr mir für Methodiken bereitstellen, damit ich das effizienter durchführen kann?
Unser Ziel ist, wie gesagt, für alle Bereiche der Software-Entwicklung dann Methodiken und Werkzeuge bereitzustellen, die relativ einfach zu lernen sind und keinen großen Overhead bedeuten. Auch wenn sie nicht im Sinne der reinen Software-Engineering-Lehre sozusagen das Non-Product-Ultra sind. Aber im DLR ist auch die Situation, dass im Grunde jede Gruppe und jede Software ist anders.
Das ist ja ein extrem weites Feld mit zahlreichen Betriebssystemen und unterschiedlichen Computersystemen, die zum Einsatz kommen. Und Poemiersprachen will ich gar nicht anfangen.
Deswegen haben wir auch nicht den Anspruch, dass wir alles abdecken können. Das wird nicht gehen. Und einige Leute sind auch sehr weit, die machen das sowieso traditionell schon sehr gut. Auch gerade die Leute, die wirklich Raumfahrt-Software entwickeln, also auch echtzeitfähige Systeme und ähnliches, die nutzen ja auch schon kommerzielle Werkzeuge, z.B. Recurvements, Analyse und ähnliches, machen das sehr gut. Haben auch teilweise Vorgaben von außen von den Auftraggebern. Aber es gibt ja auch andere Gruppen, die machen andere Gruppen und den Software-Entwicklern, die machen quasi nichts. Also eine ganz, ganz große Bandbreite. Und das Ziel unserer Gruppe ist ja, sozusagen den Durchschnitt ein bisschen zu heben. Also die, die das so und so schon ganz toll machen, da können wir auch nichts mehr verbessern. Die machen das schon besser als wir. Wir wollen aber so am unteren Ende die ein bisschen hochschieben und auch den großen Teil in der Mitte noch dem noch ein bisschen helfen, das noch ein bisschen zu verbessern. Also insgesamt, in der Summe wollen wir das Qualitätsniveau der Software im DLR ein bisschen anheben. Das ist eigentlich das Ziel.
Das gelingt euch auch?
Das gelingt uns auch, ja.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wenn man sich jetzt mal denkt, ich bin jetzt eine Forschungsabteilung, wir haben jetzt irgendwie ein DLR, wir wollen da halt irgendwie an was arbeiten. Man hat dann einen Stamm von Leuten und vielleicht auch so einige neue und man überlegt sich, okay, alles klar. Wir wollen jetzt hier eine Simulationssoftware bauen, um dieses und jenes Raumfahrtprojekt neu durchzurechnen. Und jetzt könnte man sich mit euch zusammen tun. Welche Art von Architektur würdet ihr denn so üblicherweise vermitteln? Ein paar Sachen hast du jetzt schon angesprochen, hast gesagt, okay, am Anfang müsst ihr erstmal eine konkrete Analyse eurer Anforderungen machen. Gut, nachvollziehbar. Und es wäre klug, sowas wie Ischutrecker, Backtrecker etc. zu verwenden. Das ist ja noch lange nicht alles. Vielleicht kann man ja mal so ein theoretisches Projekt oder auch ein konkretes, wenn dir das einfällt, durchspielen, wo ihr sozusagen so ein Gesamtgerüst auch vermittelt und empfohlen habt, wie man sozusagen mit Software arbeiten sollte.
Ja, also allgemein gesprochen ist das sehr unterschiedlich. Es ist klar, wir empfehlen natürlich nicht jedem das Gleiche, weil es in den meisten Fällen nicht passt. Wenn wir was empfehlen, auch erstmal gucken, was sind die Anforderungen, was hat man im Sinn. Auch teilweise, was gibt es schon an Software in der jeweiligen Abteilung, wo man darauf aufsetzen kann oder muss. Und davon hängt das ja ab. Davon hängt die Programmiersprache oft ab. Davon hängt die Architektur der Software ab. Und ähnliche Sachen. Es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Als es zum Beispiel darum ging, so etwas wie Strömungslöser zu aktualisieren, die etwas moderner zu machen in der Benutzbarkeit.
Strömungslöser?
Da geht es um Berechnung von Strömung um Flugzeuge herum, zum Beispiel um das Äußere von Flugzeugen, also um Flügel oder ähnliches. Oder auch Strömung in Turbinen, zum Beispiel, im Bereich der Flugzeugantriebe. Da gibt es traditionell schon Software, die sowas simulieren kann und berechnen kann. Also numerische Strömungsimulation oder CFD, Computational Fluid Dynamics ist das Schlagwort. Und die wurde ursprünglich oft in solchen Programmiersprachen wie Fortran oder später in einem reinen C geschrieben. Das ist aber dann oft nicht sehr komfortabel in der Programmierung. Der Vorteil von solchen Programmiersprachen ist, sie sind unglaublich schnell und performant. Weil auch die Compiler für solche Sprachen sehr lange Tradition haben und sehr hoch optimiert sind. Auch für alle möglichen Arten von Rechnersystemen zum Beispiel.
Gut abgehangen.
Gut abgehangen, genau. Gerade war Fortran ein großes Argument. Es gibt natürlich auch unglaublich viele Software schon, die in C oder Fortran geschrieben sind, wo man auch aufsetzen kann. Andererseits ist es nicht besonders komfortabel beim Programmieren. Da kann man auch darüber streiten, was ist komfortabel und was nicht. Das ist eine interessante Randdiskussion bei allen möglichen Gelegenheiten natürlich. Aber wenn man z.B. an eine objektorientierte Programmierung denkt, und das ist so ein Schritt vorwärts, oder noch eine Ebene höher, gibt es auch die Script-Programmierung, die man einsetzen kann, um z.B. ein Hauptprogramm von so einer Simulationssoftware zu schreiben. Und ein Fall, den wir oft empfehlen, ist z.B., wenn man schon ganz viele numerische Methoden zum Berechnen, zum Simulieren hat, in Fortran oder C und die das Ganze aktualisieren möchte oder moderner machen möchte, der Vorschlag ist, die einfach nicht zu ändern, sondern zu integrieren in andere programmierte Sprachen. Ein häufiger Fall ist z.B., dass man C- oder Fortran-Routinen einfach in Python z.B. integriert und als Python-Modul einbittet und das Rahmenprogramm dann einfach als Python-Script schreibt, wo man dann sehr komfortabel alles Mögliche machen kann, so Parametervariation oder Optimierungsrechnung usw. Aber die eigentliche Berechnung, die sehr CPU-lastig ist und sehr viel Rechenzeit erfordert, die bleibt weiter in den Fortran- oder C-Routinen, teilweise inzwischen auch C++-Routinen. Das hat auch noch den Vorteil, diese Routinen sind oft auch seit langer Zeit entwickelt und auch getestet und validiert. Weil das Problem ist ja immer, wenn man Software neu schreibt, schreibt man ja nicht nur die Software und die Funktionen, die sie dann erfüllt, sondern man schreibt ja auch neue Fehler da rein.
Lecker neue Fehler.
Es ist ja kein großer Spaß, davon neu anzufangen und jahrelang Bucktracking zu machen in so einer Software oder das mit irgendwelchen numerischen Modellen zu verifizieren und zu validieren, also ob das Ergebnis, was da rauskommt, auch physikalisch richtig ist zum Beispiel. Wenn man eine neue Software schreibt, müsste man das alles dann nochmal machen. Und das ist oft sinnvoller, so alte Software einfach so zu lassen und sozusagen einen neuen Rahmen drum zu stricken, der das Ganze dann etwas komfortabler macht.
Fehler. Wer sich schon mal mit Software auseinandergesetzt hat, wird feststellen, dass es davon eine Menge gibt, bzw. man macht am laufenden Meter welche und das ist an der Stelle, wo es darum geht, eine Berechnung durchzuführen. Das ist ja das, was Computer letzten Endes tun. Es ist ja eigentlich geboten, keine mehr zu machen. Nun treten sie trotzdem auf. So wie ich das beobachtet habe, hat sich in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren in diesem gesamten Software-Diskurs verschiedene Trends breit gemacht. Eins davon unter dem Namen Test-Driven-Development. Dass man also versucht, seine Software während der Entwicklung schon möglichst viel eigenen Tests auszusetzen. Inwiefern ist das Teil eurer Arbeit?
Das ist ein großer Teil. Wir selbst entwickeln ja auch Software. Wir nutzen Test-Driven-Development natürlich für unsere eigene Software. Wir schreiben Unit-Tests vorher und hinter Systemtests. Und wir vermitteln das auch anderen.
Also Unit-Tests, wenn man so einzelne Teile prüft.
Ja, genau. Auf unterster Ebene, die einfachsten Tests. Es gibt ja oft so Vorschläge, man soll erst die Tests schreiben und dann die Software. Das ist ja ein Teil von Test-Driven-Development. Und das vermitteln wir auch anderen Leuten im DLR. Ein paar Kollegen von uns zum Beispiel bieten Schulungen im DLR an für Softwareentwicklung. Und da ist das Thema Testen, Test-Driven-Development, die Nutzung von Test-Tools, einer der Schwerpunkte für Programmersprachen wie Java oder C zum Beispiel. Genau.
Da wo besonders viele Fehler auftauchen.
Ja, nee, wo auch relativ viele Leute mit entwickeln im DLR. Also es würden ja alle möglichen Programmersprachen benutzt. Ich hab mal für einen Vortrag irgendwie gesammelt, so eine Folie erstellt, um die mal alle aufzulisten. Da hab ich dann mal 35 Programmersprachen aufgehört.
Ich weiß nicht, die so aktiv im Einsatz sind.
Die so aktiv im Einsatz sind, genau. Das sind natürlich so die Klassiker Java, C, C++, Python, Fortran, C Sharp, das ist da alles bei. Aber auch da zählt dann natürlich auch sowas drunter. So spezielle Sprachen, die außerhalb der Wissenschaft und Technik oft nicht so verwendet werden wie Matlab zum Beispiel. Das ist eine Sprache, die sehr, sehr häufig im DLR verwendet wird.
Für mathematische, numerische Sachen, genau.
Oder Steuerung von irgendwas, genau.
Fallen dir noch ein paar ein?
Programmersprachen, ansonsten.
Also die jetzt vielleicht noch eine besondere Verbreitung haben?
Ja, relativ verbreitet sind noch so Scriptsprachen wie normale Shell-Skripte oder Perl und sowas. Tickel und ähnliches.
Eigentlich so alles, was die Softwareentwicklung in den letzten 30 Jahren hergegeben hat?
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Das könnt ihr ja gar nicht alles supporten, oder?
Nein, machen wir auch nicht. Wir konzentrieren uns auf die Sprachen, die am weitesten verbreitet sind. Oder wo Leute mit konkreten Fragen oder Anforderungen oder mit Bedarf kommen. Das ist gar nicht zu machen.
Software Engineering ist ja auch nicht auf eine Sprache gemünzt, sondern ist ja mehr eine allgemeine Herangehensweise an Entwicklung.
Genau. Wir vermitteln in den Schulungen auch viel so was, wie man allgemein mit Werkzeugen zur Softwareentwicklung umgeht. Heutzutage gibt es nicht mehr gerne Eclipse als Entwicklungsumgebung für Software. Damit kann man ja für alle möglichen Programmiersprachen entwickeln. Das ist sich über Plugins erweitern. Wir vermitteln natürlich erstmal in so Schulungen auch, wie man Eclipse überhaupt benutzt. Das ist dann zweitrangig für welche Programmiersprache das ist. Wir machen das in Java oder C oder auch Python. Aber das ist eigentlich dann zweitrangig. Und ein anderer Aspekt ist ja auch, wie man die Software verwaltet. Also ein Versionsverwaltungssystem für die Software. Also was wie Subversion oder Mercurial oder CBS. Da gibt es eine ganze Reihe. Die werden schon viel eingesetzt im DLR, aber auch noch nicht flächendeckend. Und auch das wird in den Schulungen vermittelt. Also wie man mit so einem Versionsverwaltungssystem arbeitet und wie man das ganze Konfigurationsmanagement der Software macht. Wie man neue Releases anlegt und Branches der Software und ähnliches. Und das anhand von konkreten Programmierbeispielen. Und dazu gehört dann eben auch das Testen. Man schreibt Unit-Tests und wie baut man das in die Dateistruktur ein? Wo liegen die Tests? Wie arbeitet man mit dem Releasionsmanagement etc.?
Klingt für mich so, als hätte die Enformen einen hohen Schulungsbedarf. Also es wäre jetzt ein Hauptteil der Tätigkeit wirklich so etwas. Jetzt hast du ja auch eingangs gesagt, ihr forschst ja auch selbst quasi an euren Themen. Wie viel Zeit bleibt denn dafür eigentlich noch?
Für die Forschung selber?
Ja, ja.
Das ist so unterschiedlich. Das machen ja unterschiedliche Leute eigentlich. Oder beispielsweise Leute machen mal dies und mal das. Also diese Schulung ist so ein bisschen das Surface-Charakter, der aber garantiert nicht immer ist. Also die Kollegen, die das machen, machen hauptberuflich eigentlich ganz andere Sachen. Oder zum Großteil ihrer Zeit. Der eine, der da immer mitmacht, der arbeitet zum Beispiel den meisten Teil seiner Zeit an so einem Strömungslöser mit und entwickelt da. Und der andere, der ist für Software-Engineering zuständig, klar, der beschäftigt sich mit dem Thema Software-Engineering ganz allgemein. Und diese Schulungen, die finden dann ein, zwei Mal im Monat statt vielleicht.
Ich meine, man kann ja auch nicht nur Schulungen geben. Wo soll man denn dann die Erfahrungen hernehmen?
Ja, genau, genau. Also bei uns ist eh die Philosophie, dass natürlich, wenn wir über Software-Engineering und Softwareentwicklung reden und das anderen Leuten beibringen wollen oder erklären wollen, dann müssen wir selber Erfahrungen haben auf dem Gebiet. Also, wenn jetzt nicht die Software-Engineering-Experten, die das noch nie programmiert haben, also wir haben, wir kommen eigentlich alle aus der Programmiererecke oder programmieren auch aktiv selber mit und vermitteln das und dann unser Praxiswissen weiter. Also quasi niemals theoretisches Wissen, das wir weiter vermitteln, sondern alles getestet bei uns. Auf einer anderen Ebene getestet.
Praxis. Praxis getestet, geprüft, genau. Was muss man denn jetzt sozusagen, also mit was für Art von Software habt ihr es denn so zu tun? In der DLR-Welt. Also ich meine Programme, das ist jetzt erstmal ein sehr allgemeiner Begriff. Was wird denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich in den Instituten so vor allem entwickelt? Mit welcher Art Software seid ihr konfrontiert? Worauf bezieht sich die Arbeit so im Wesentlichen?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also im DLR ist ja die Situation nochmal allgemeiner. Wir haben etwa 30 wissenschaftliche Institute, immerhin 6.500 Mitarbeiter, wovon etwa 1000 Mitarbeiter Software entwickeln. Vollzeit sozusagen, umgerechnet auf Vollzeitstelle. Einige machen das in Teilzeitmitarbeiter und entwickeln nur zum Teil ihrer Zeit Software, aber hochgerechnet auf Vollzeit sind das etwa 1000 Mitarbeiter, die Software entwickeln.
Das ist schon viel.
Das ist viel. Wir sind sicherlich eine der größten Softwarehäuser in Deutschland, wenn man das so sehen will. Natürlich gibt es Firmen, die da mehr machen und so. Das mit dem größten, das würde ich jetzt nicht unterschreiben, das ist klar. Aber auch gerade im Wissenschaftsbereich gibt es sicherlich nicht viele Einrichtungen, die mehr Software entwickeln als wir. Wenn ich sage Software-Haus, das ist natürlich schon irreführend. Wir sind ja kein Software-Haus natürlich. Vieles von unserer Software ist ja auch gar nicht so verfügbar für andere. Das ist ja das... Alle größte Teile ist ja sozusagen für interne Aufgaben. Und zu deiner Frage, welche Arten von Software gibt es? Also ganz grob gibt es dann vier Klassen von Software. Vier Arten, wie wir das ein bisschen unterscheiden. Die erste ist, da geht es sehr stark um das Thema eingebettete Systeme oder echtzeitfähige Software. Also die sehr nah an technischen Systemen läuft. Die zum Beispiel irgendwas misst und steuert und regelt etc. Und dann wenn man auch Anforderungen an Echtzeit hat, also um natürlich ein Raumfahrzeug oder ein Flugzeug zu steuern zum Beispiel. Da gibt es auch in einigen Fachinstituten Spezialisten, die sich dann auf sowas sehr stark konzentrieren. Und Mitarbeiter von uns aus Braunschweig zum Beispiel, die arbeiten da auch mit und fokussieren sich dann sehr stark aber zum Beispiel auch auf den Software-Test von solcher Software oder Software-Architekturen für sowas. Ja, genau. Die zweite Art von Software, das ist ein Bereich, wo wir persönlich relativ wenig mit zu tun haben. Das sind sowas wie Unternehmensanwendungen, webbasierte Internet- und Intranet-Anwendungen oder irgendwie e-mailbasiert oder ähnliches. Klasse und Intranet-Portale mit administrativen Workflows etc. Das wird auch teilweise im DLR entwickelt, teilweise dann auch mit externen Beratern dabei. Aber da halten wir uns erstmal raus, das ist nicht unsere Baustelle. Aber es gibt auch so Portallösungen, die wir auch entwickeln, zum Beispiel webbasiert, um Informationen bereitzustellen, also wissenschaftliche Informationen. Das machen wir gerade Mitarbeiter aus meiner Abteilung, gerade für Informationen aus dem Flughafenbereich, zum Beispiel Flughafen, WSNU, wo Informationen europaweit bereitgestellt werden können. Oder es gibt zum Beispiel auch so einen Webshop von DLR, wo man Satellitendaten kaufen kann. Wo Banken oder Versicherungen dann ausgewertete Satellitenbilder bekommen können.
Aber das ist sozusagen nicht so der Hauptfokus?
Das ist nicht der Hauptfokus, ne? Das kommt ab und zu mal vor. Ein weiterer Bereich ist Software zur Unterstützung von anderen Aufgaben. Da fallen zum Beispiel Software-Bruktur runter, wie zum Beispiel Datenmanagementsysteme oder Workflow-Managementsysteme. Oder allgemein Simulationsumgebungen, Integrationssysteme. Das heißt also, wo man andere Software integrieren kann. Also zum Beispiel numerische Simulationssoftware, die irgendwo läuft, kann man integrieren. Dadurch bekommen die dann oft eine grafische Benutzeroberfläche. Und man kann die Daten, die dort erzeugt werden, managen, verwalten, vielleicht archivieren zum Beispiel. Das ist ein relativ großer Bereich und das wird eigentlich auch in ganz vielen DLR-Instituten gebraucht. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Art von Software, wo wir in unserer Gruppe sehr viel entwickeln, weil das natürlich nicht so fachspezifisch ist. Also das ist eigentlich nicht Aufgabe der Fachinstitute, solche Software zu entwickeln, sondern das ist ja sehr übergreifend. Und wir stellen zum Beispiel Software bereit, die zum Beispiel Datenmanagement erledigt, wo man alle Arten von wissenschaftlichen Daten mit verwalten kann oder archivieren kann.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz dabei. Also so mit Daten umzugehen ist ja denke ich mal im Forschungsbereich kein unwichtiges Thema. Es fallen eine Menge an. Man berechnet die ganze Zeit neue. Was umfasst denn das Datenmanagement? Also geht es jetzt hier um die Speicherung, die Archivierung, das Auffinden, Suchen, alles Mögliche oder was?
Genau, alles Mögliche und zwar auch alles, was du aufgelistet hast. Ein Beispiel ist ja zum Beispiel, das tritt oft auf bei numerischer Simulationen, also zum Beispiel so diese Strömungssimulationen oder ähnliche Sachen. Diese Simulationen, die erzeugen unglaublich große Datenmengen inzwischen. Also falls im Gigabyte-Bereich, die Simulationen werden ja auch auf großen Parallelrechnern durchgeführt, wo jeder auf jeder CPU sozusagen einzelne Daten erzeugt werden. Das sind ganz große Datenmengen, die man natürlich erstmal auswerten muss, irgendwo hin kopieren muss und später dann auch archivieren muss, wenn man es möchte. Klar, da geht es um Sachen, die auch sehr Richtung Technik gehen. Also wie kriegt man Daten überhaupt von einem Großrechner runter auf lokale Systeme zum Auswerten? Manchmal geht das gar nicht, wenn die viel zu groß sind. Dann lässt man die am besten da und wärtet die vor Ort aus. Das nennt sich dann Post-Processing, also Nachverarbeiten der Daten. Das macht man am besten lokal auf so einem Großrechner, gleich auf so einem High-Performance-System drauf. Und holt sich dann nur die ausgewerteten Daten runter. Die sind dann in der Regel sehr viel kleiner. Aber wenn man die Daten dann auch lokal hat, normalerweise führt man ja ganz viele Simulationen hintereinander aus. Für verschiedene Designs oder verschiedene Parametereinstellungen und ähnliches. Oder wenn man Optimierungsrechnungen durchführt, in jedem Optimierungskreislauf wird dann die Simulation zum Beispiel durchgeführt. Das können auch mehrere Simulationen sein. Und da fallen in jedem Schritt dann wieder Daten an. Und da geht es auch zum Beispiel darum, diese Daten, die erzeugt werden, zu verwalten. Und auch so irgendwie abzulegen, dass man sie selber wiederfindet. Und auch, dass andere Kollegen die finden können. Es ist ja klar, die Menschen sind ja nicht doof. Und man kann natürlich seinen eigenen Arbeitsbereich immer so organisieren, dass man alles wiederfindet. Sein eigenes Home Directory, ja. Aber das geht dann schief, wenn man mit anderen Kollegen zusammenarbeitet und andere Kollegen brauchen diese Daten. Oder würden gerne eine Rechnung durchführen und mal wissen, wer hat das Gleiche schon mal gerechnet, wen kann ich da fragen, welche Daten kann ich schon mal als Ausgangspunkt benutzen.
Aber setzt das nicht voraus, dass man dann auch so quasi einen zentralen Datenspeicher hat für alles?
Nicht fürs DLR, nein, aber mehr so in Abteilung. Also für alles, dass sich ja nicht auch für die Art der Daten natürlich sehr unterschiedlich sind und weil das, was so Satelliten-Leute machen, ja so Strömungsmechaniker eigentlich nicht interessiert. Das macht von da keinen Sinn. Aber so lokal gibt es dann halt zentrale Datenserver, wo die Daten drauf liegen und auch so drauf liegen, dass sie wieder auffindbar sind. Also das heißt, da liegen nicht nur in Verzeichnissen oder auf Servern die nackten Datendateien, sondern da gibt es dann immer beschreibende Daten oder Metadaten dazu, wo man danach suchen kann. Also wo zum Beispiel der Projektname drin steht, der Name des Bearbeiters, wer das erzeugt hat, oder wichtige Parametereinstellungen und so weiter. Da kann man sich alles Mögliche überlegen. Und auch Metadaten, die automatisch extrahiert wurden aus den Simulationsergebnissen. Also irgendwelche Kennzahlen zum Beispiel, die automatisch mit Skripten raus extrahiert werden. Die werden als Metadaten hinzugefügt und dann kann man sehr komfortabel danach suchen.
Unterhält denn das DLR eigene Datenzentren dafür? Oder ist das wirklich wieder so am Institut zu sein?
Das ist das meistlokale Institut.
Ich erinnere mich gerade in dem Podcast, den wir hier in der Reihe gemacht haben über Erdbeobachtung. Da war natürlich die Datenmenge, die dort anfiel, auch extrem. Da war dann auch die Rede von einem etwas größeren Archivsystem mit Robotern, Tape-Robotern etc. Weißt du da was drüber?
Ja, ein bisschen. Das ist aber nicht unbedingt mein Gebiet. Die spezialisieren sich sehr stark darauf und sind da auch sehr gut. Wir beschäftigen uns damit eher nicht, weil wir denen auch nichts Neues erzählen können. Diesen Kollegen in der UR Pfaffenhofen zum Beispiel, deutsches Fernerkundungsdatenzentrum. Unsere Baustelle sind eher die Leute, die da noch nichts haben. Das sind ein Großteil des Restes sozusagen, der anderen 30 DLR-Institute. Wenn man von nichts hat, dann muss man natürlich erst mal irgendwas aufbauen. Da geht es dann eher darum, so lokale Server aufzubauen und bereitzustellen, wo Leute oder Arbeitsgruppen oder Projekte dann ihre Daten ablegen können. Da sind dann die Datenmengen meist noch überschaubar, aber im Laufe der Zeit wachsen die auch natürlich an, ist ja klar.
Simulation steht ja jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen im Mittelpunkt aus deiner Arbeit. Und steht aber auch generell im Mittelpunkt vieler Forscher im DLR. Weil darum geht es, es geht darum, neue Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen. Und viel davon muss einfach simuliert werden, insbesondere dann eben auch in der Raumfahrt, wo man ja nicht mal eben mal was fliegen lassen kann, sondern wo man ja im besten Fall schon vorher weiß, wie es wahrscheinlich fliegen wird. Und das Ganze dann eben auch mit so einer hohen Genauigkeit durchführen muss. Das sind ja nicht gerade geringe Anforderungen, so zu verhindern, dass irgendwas vom Himmel fällt, was an dem 15 Jahre lang gebaut wurde und was, weiß ich, wie viel Geld verschlungen hat, so über die Zeit. Was für Systeme kommen da überhaupt zum Einsatz? Es ist jetzt wirklich so, dass jeder da an seiner eigenen Sache muckelt oder gibt es so verschiedene Basissysteme, die da primär zum Einsatz kommen?
Also, von Basissystemen, die ganz weite Verbreitung haben, kann man nicht sprechen. Vieles, was wir in dem Bereich Simulationssoftware haben, im DLR, ist für die verschiedenen Teilbereiche sehr individuell entwickelt worden. Meistens im DLR. Es gibt auch für ähnliche Aufgaben verschiedene Entwicklungen, die in verschiedenen Instituten durchgeführt wurden. Und es gibt natürlich auch Bereiche, wo so was wie Standardsoftware eingesetzt wird, also Dazugekaufte, die auch außerhalb des DLRs in ganz vielen Bereichen eingesetzt wird. Aber in der Regel wird für unsere Aufgaben das Individualsoftware, die die Institute eigentlich selber entwickeln, und die dann irgendwie einen speziellen Schwerpunkt haben oder optimiert werden für irgendwelche speziellen Aufgaben. Und da halt besonders gut funktionieren. Das ist ja auch das Ziel. Also wenn man nicht denkt, dass man die Software besser machen würde als das, was man am Markt kaufen kann, dann braucht man die ja nicht neu entwickeln.
Andererseits, wenn man jetzt immer wieder alles neu entwickelt, bzw. wenn man so spezielle Anforderungen hat, das schreit ja dann auch so ein bisschen nach Open Source-Systemen. Wenn man sich nicht alles kaufen will und wenn man aber trotzdem die Möglichkeit haben will, das so anzupassen, wie man es eben braucht, welche Rolle spielt denn Open Source in dem ganzen Kontext?
Immer größere. Es ist sicher nicht so, dass nur Open Source eingesetzt wird. Es gibt auch viele Software, die gekauft wird, auch einfach weil sie gut ist oder weil man nicht viel mehr machen könnte. Aber die Rolle von Open Source wird eigentlich immer größer. Das ist vor allem erstmal merkbar an Open Source Software, die man für die Entwicklung als Entwicklungstools natürlich und auch an so was wie Bibliotheken, also Libraries oder irgendwelche Tools, die man in der eigenen Software integriert. Also um sich eigene Arbeit zu sparen bei der Entwicklung. Also wir hatten mal eine Software entwickelt für den deutschen Schiffbau, also für Werften. Da wollten die Werften Schiffe mit entwerfen, also früher Entwurf von Schiffen. Da ging es um so eine Integrations- und Simulationsumgebung mit Grafschaublen und Soberfläche. Und von der gesamten Software, die dann am Ende rauskam, haben wir in jedem Fall deutlich unter 20% entwickelt. Der Rest ist das, was durch die Open Source-Projekte und Produkte wie Eclipse und ähnliches schon mitkommt. Und das ist eigentlich auch das Ziel. Ich meine, diese Software ist ja meistens sehr gut. Viele Projekte haben ja sehr viele Nutzer und sind dadurch auch viel getestet und werden schnell und viel weiterentwickelt zum Beispiel. Das macht dann überhaupt nicht vernünftig, dann selber das Ganze alles nochmal neu zu programmieren, weil man jetzt denkt, man könnte es ja eigentlich besser. Weil oftmals, also meistens kann man das nicht.
Was kommen Sie denn zum Einsatz? Aus dem Open-Source-Bereich meinst du? Man hat Linux oder man verwendet jetzt als Open-Source verwendete Programmiersprachen. Also gibt es größere Pakete aus der Open-Source-Welt, die jetzt auch speziell für die Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik eine besondere Bedeutung haben, weil sie einfach eine Plattform darstellen, auf der man eben gut Simulationen oder andere Systeme entwickeln kann.
Also das herausragende ist sicherlich Eclipse und diese Eclipse-Plattform. Also es werden sehr viele Systeme auf Grundlage von Eclipse entwickelt. Simulationssoftware zum Beispiel, die einfach als Eclipserweiterung programmiert werden. Da steckt dann Eclipse hinter und man programmiert eine Eclipse-Erweiterung.
Aber Eclipse ist doch vor allem eine Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, Eclipse ist eigentlich eine Plattform, um eigene Anwendungen zu erstellen. Und ein Beispiel ist ja quasi eine Entwicklungsumgebung. Das ist auch das, was man bei Eclipse dann runterladen kann. Das ist natürlich dann vorkonfiguriert für Java-Entwicklung oder für allgemein Software-Entwicklung. Aber da ist die Eclipse-Plattform auf unterster Ebene. Und darüber sind schon Erweiterungen für die Software-Entwicklung zum Beispiel. Und wir machen das oft im DLR, das machen ganz viele Gruppen so. Wir machen halt eigene Erweiterungen zum Beispiel, um Workflows abzuarbeiten oder Visualisierungen zu machen. Oder die Simulationscodes werden direkt als Eclips-Erweiterung geschrieben oder ähnliches. Die Basis unter Eclipse ist ja dieses Komponent-Modell OSGI, heißt das. Das ist ein Komponent-Modell für Java. Also wir sind hier erstmal nur in der Java-Welt. Auf andere Programmersprachen gibt es dann andere Beispiele. Aber das ist ja die Basis drunter. Und auf dessen Basis, auf diesem Komponent-Modell, wird das Eclipse drauf aufgebaut. Und auch auf dieser untersten Ebene gibt es dann auch Beispiele, wo darauf aufgesetzt wird. Also wir zum Beispiel entwickeln in meiner Gruppe eine Telemedizin-Anwendung, die also auf Smartphones heutzutage läuft. Also wo auf Basis von OSGi eine Applikation entwickelt wurde, die über Bluetooth, zum Beispiel Blutzucker und Blutdruck, Messwerte aufnimmt oder Gewicht von der Elektronik und Waage. Und das dann weiter versendet an medizinische Expertenzentren oder Serviceeinrichtungen oder Ärzte, wo es dann ausgewertet wird. Diese Smartphone-Applikation, die ist mit der gleichen Technologie entwickelt worden wie zum Beispiel C-Clips. Das ist ja schon bei Weiterbau modular und anpassbar. Das hat den Vorteil, dass man ganz ähnliche Technologien in verschiedenen Bereichen einsetzen kann, ohne großartig umdenken zu müssen. Auf der Desktop-Ebene ist es so, wenn man das Eclipse nimmt, mit dem ganzen Eclipse-Ekosystem, was dahinter steckt, da gibt es ja schon unglaublich viele Erweiterungen von allen möglichen Leuten in der Welt. Wenn wir jetzt eine Gesamteinwendung entwickeln wollen, ein Simulationssystem oder Ähnliches, dann können wir ja schon ganz viel nehmen. So Sachen wie Visualisierung, die schon fast fertig sind oder grafische Editoren, um irgendwelche Sachen zu editieren. Das alles in der Regel ist sehr viel schon da. Wir müssen dann nur ganz spezifische Erweiterungen programmieren und dann kriegen wir in relativ kurzer Zeit eine Gesamtanwendung, die sehr leistungsfähig ist.
Das klingt aber jetzt so, als ob das so die Wunderwelt, Open Source, ich lag mir da was runter und dann läuft das alles schon. Das klingt ja schon so, als würde man ja gar keine Forschung betreiben müssen. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der Anpassungsbedarf zumindest im Einzelfall nicht unerheblich ist. Also dass man zwar jetzt eine gute Basis hat, aber ja eigentlich auch häufig, so kenne ich das, sagen wir mal in so Einschränkungen hineinläuft, wo man sich denkt so, okay, alles klar, diese Software könnte zwar grundsätzlich für mich geeignet sein, aber hat jetzt an dieser Stelle so eine Einschränkung, die hier einfach mal gar nicht passt. Das erfordert ja dann schon auch eine Initiative, das dann für seine eigenen Zwecke anzupassen, wo es eben nicht so ist, dass ich sage, okay, ist ja schon alles fertig, kann ich benutzen, ich kann mich auf meine eigentliche Arbeit konzentrieren, sondern dass man eben auch an diesen Systemen quasi mitentwickeln muss.
Ja.
Findet das statt?
Ja, das findet statt.
Welcher Form?
Ja, je nach Art des Projekts natürlich. Oft sind diese Open-Source-Projekte ja auf Plattformen gehostet. Also da liegt der Source-Code auf solchen Plattformen wie SourceForge oder Google-Code. Und dann kann man einfach mitentwickeln. Und das machen auch Leute von uns, je nachdem. Oder wir haben zum Beispiel auch so ein Projekt quasi, also die Projektleitung dann übernommen, wenn man von Projektleitung sprechen will. Ein Beispiel ist ein Webduff-Server. Webduff ist also ein Protokoll.
Auf Basis von HTTP?
Auf Basis von HTTP, um Dateien hochzuladen, runterzuladen und einfach zu verwalten auf dem Server. Und das brauchen wir als Grundlage für einige unserer Datenmanagementsysteme. Da brauchen wir einfach einen Webduff-Server. Da hatten wir mal angefangen früher mit kommerziellen Servern, haben dann aber beschlossen, dass wir auf Open Source umstellen wollen. Und dann gibt es dann eben verschiedene Open Source-Server. Ein Server, der schien schon ganz gut zu sein, der heißt Catacomb, war aber nicht perfekt. Da hat er einige Features, die haben einfach gefehlt. Sowas wie Rechte und Rollenmanagement zum Beispiel, war da nicht drin. Und das haben wir dann erweitert dort. Erst mal ein Kollege, der inzwischen bei uns Mitarbeiter ist, hat im Rahmen seiner Diplomarbeit das Ding um Rechtemanagement erweitert. Und dann später als Mitarbeiter war er dann auch da weitergemacht. Und der hat dann sozusagen auch die Koordination dieser Weiterentwicklung von diesem Catacombserver übernommen.
Aber wie weit geht das? Habt ihr auch Leute in euren Reihen, die jetzt selber diese Open Source-Projekte entwickeln? Also es ist ja in den USA, auch im kommerziellen Bereich, vielleicht nicht üblich, aber häufig anzutreffen, dass eben in diesen Unternehmen gesagt wird, dieses Werkzeug, das ist für uns so wichtig, da schauen wir uns doch lieber mal gleich um, nach den Original-Developern, spricht mit denen und stellt die irgendwie ein. Und dann machen die was weiß ich in dem Unternehmen, aber eben einen Teil ihrer Arbeit, der eben normalerweise in der Freizeit in diese Software gehen würde, geht dann eben auch während der Arbeitszeit rein. Ist der DLR jetzt auch schon so ein Ort, wo Open-Source-Entwicklung gefördert wird oder selbst stattfindet? Also wo tatsächlich ein Code, den auch andere Leute nutzen können, wieder um nach außen geht? Über normale Änderungen an bestehenden Paketen hinaus?
Ja, also grundsätzlich schon. Wir machen jetzt schon Änderungen an Software, wie du gesagt hast. Ich kenne jetzt keinen Fall, wo wir wirklich mit Absicht jemanden eingestellt haben oder zielgerichtet jemanden eingestellt haben, der dann für uns an einer speziellen Software weiterentwickelt. Aber wenn das notwendig ist, würden wir das doch machen. Für uns ist die Sache natürlich sehr wichtig. Was wir eher machen, ist zum Beispiel auch eigene Open Source-Projekte anzubieten. Also eigene Software als Open Source zu veröffentlichen. Das ist im Moment noch der Fall, der deutlich häufiger vorkommt.
Hast du da mal ein paar Beispiele, was so als Software selbst wiederum veröffentlicht wurde, aus dem DLR heraus?
Ja, also wir haben zum Beispiel bei uns aus der Gruppe kommt eine Software, die heißt DataFinder, die ist zum Datemanagement. Die kann dann jeder Mann bei dieser Plattform launchpad.net hingehen und dort mit entwickeln. Das sind grafische Applikationen, also mit einer grafischen Benutzeroberfläche in Python entwickelt, also in der Scriptsprache. Es gibt schon ein paar externe Entwickler, die dann auch da mitarbeiten und das auch benutzen. Und ein anderer Beispiel ist zum Beispiel dieser angesprochene Catacom Server. Der ist jetzt nicht von uns initiiert, aber wird von uns weitergetrieben. Das ist zum Beispiel auch der richtige Server, der zu diesem Datemanagement gehört. Deswegen hatten wir auch das Interesse, den weiterzuentwickeln. Ein Kollege von uns hat einen Großteil seiner Zeit dafür zur Verfügung bekommen, diesen Server auch weiterzuentwickeln. Er ist dann mal für ein paar Monate auch nach USA zur NASA gefahren, weil die den Server eben auch benutzen und auch Interesse an der Weiterentwicklung haben. Und hat mal eben die Arbeit zusammengetan.
Ist das jetzt nur so, das Open Source ist so ganz nett? Oder würdest du auch sagen, dass das eigentlich schon eine Strategie ist? Dass man eigentlich so versucht, möglichst viel auch offen zu entwickeln, auch innerhalb der Institution, da mehr Austausch zu ermöglichen?
Das ist keine festgeschriebene Strategie vom Vorstand zum Beispiel. Aber auf unterer Ebene ist das in vielen Einrichtungen und Abteilungen schon eine Strategie, dass man zum einen Open Source Software nutzt und da Open Source Software veröffentlicht und zur Verfügung stellt. Also auch nicht nur aus meiner Gruppe natürlich. Es gibt andere Beispiele, eigentlich aus allen Bereichen des DLR, die schon Open Source Software anbieten oder ihre Projekte veröffentlichen oder darüber nachdenken. Da sind oftmals natürlich auch Fragen, welche Lizenz nimmt man und so rechtliche Sachen, die man erklären muss. Aber auch da gibt es inzwischen im DLR Unterstützung. Es gibt bei uns im DLR eine Einrichtung, die nennt sich Technologie-Marketing. Die hilft so ein bisschen beim Verwerten von eigenen Entwicklungen. Die machen natürlich sehr viel traditionell für so Hardware-Entwicklungen, so Ventile oder Lack und Farben und Ähnliches, was da entwickelt wird. Aber die haben zunehmend mit dem Thema Open Source zu tun. Eine Mitarbeiterin davon war zum Beispiel auch auf einer Open Source-Lizenz-Schulung.
Welche Lizenzen kommen denn zum Einsatz bisher? Was wird denn das normalerweise?
Also zum Einsatz kommt eine ganze Bandbreite. Es gibt natürlich die GPL, die traditionell so oft eingesetzt wird. Im Eclipse-Bereich natürlich die Eclipse Public License. Oder wie in unserer Gruppe haben wir uns jetzt sehr stark festgelegt auf die Apache License Version 2. Wir haben auch Software mit der BSD License und ein paar andere Sachen. Das hängt dann so ein bisschen auch von den Randbedingungen ab. Wenn man jetzt auf eine existierende Software aufsetzt und die hat eine Lizenz, dann nehmen wir die oft weiter. Und wenn wir jetzt neue Sachen einfach veröffentlichen, dann nehmen wir meistens die Apache License. Die hat sich am wenigsten kritisch eigentlich herausgestellt. Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht derjenige, der sich mit den Details der Rechte und Lizenzen auskennt. Aber wir hatten auch verschiedene Lizenzen mal von unserer Rechtsabteilung überprüfen lassen. Im Hinblick auf ist es kritisch fürs DLR, kann da irgendwas passieren oder geht uns irgendwas verloren dadurch. Und da ist die GPL relativ kritisch bewertet worden. Und sowas wie die Apache-License zweitnehmen nicht.
Der Kernunterschied ist ja, dass die GPL verschiedene Dinge ja erfordert von demjenigen, der die Software nutzt. Man ist gezwungen, Änderungen wiederum daran zu veröffentlichen. Während ja die BSD-artigen Lizenzen, unter die auch die Apache-License sind und so weit ich weiß auch die Eclipse-License im wesentlichen Feld. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so, hier nimm und werd glücklich.
Ja genau und man kann zum Beispiel auch was ganz interessantes. Die Software muss den Source-Code nicht unbedingt mitliefern, sondern kann quasi so eine Art Produkt dann ausliefern mit der Software. Also was manchmal halt notwendig ist, wenn wir Software in Industriepartner geben, dann muss ja nicht unbedingt die Software, die einen Source-Code dabei haben. Und es ist auch gar nicht wichtig, ob das eigentlich Open Source-Software ist. Der will die Software laufen haben, gibt uns vielleicht ein bisschen Geld für Beratung bei der Installation oder bei der Einführung und irgendwie Daten- oder Wissensmodellierung. Und ja, die Software läuft dann vor sich hin. Und es gibt dann einfach keine Probleme, das so zu machen mit der Apache-Lizenz, wie wir das wollen.
Jetzt haben wir uns ein bisschen sehr auf so einem allgemeinen Terrain bewegt. Das erfordert das Thema auch ein Stück weit. Trotzdem würde ich ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen mehr den Weg finden hin in die konkreten Bedürfnisse der Bereiche der Raumfahrt im DLR. Und wie sich das in der Software auswirkt. Unterscheiden sich denn für euch überhaupt die Teile, die sich jetzt konkreter mit Raumfahrt beschäftigen von den anderen Forschungssachen? Oder ist das eigentlich alles ein Bereich?
Im Wesentlichen nicht, nein. Also es ist erschreckend oft immer das Gleiche.
Aber welche Raumfahrtbereiche unterstützt ihr und wo kommt das ins Spiel?
Wo wir speziell mithelfen, ist natürlich diese Art von Unterstützungssoftware, Datenmanagement und Wissensmanagement und ähnliches. Und im Bereich der Simulationssoftware, die ist noch nicht wirklich kritisch. Die Art der Software, wie man so eine Software macht, ist auch sehr ähnlich in allen Bereichen des DLR. Raumfahrt, Luftfahrt, Energie und Verkehr. Das sind gar keine so großen Unterschiede. Und wir können oft die gleiche Software für verschiedene Gebiete benutzen. Also eine Simulationsumgebung, die funktioniert natürlich genauso für Raumfahrt wie für Luftfahrtanwendung oder Verkehrsanwendung. Das ist kein großer Unterschied. Wo es sehr spezifisch wird, wird es natürlich dann bei der Art von Software, die stark mit den technischen Systemen zusammenläuft. Also eingebettete Systemssoftware zum Beispiel oder echtzeitfähige Software, die irgendwas steuern muss. Das ist dann oft sehr Raumfahrtspezifisch. Die haben natürlich auch höhere Qualitätsanforderungen bei der Entwicklung. Das müssen die Kollegen, die Software machen, sich berücksichtigen. Aber da gibt es dann entsprechende Spezialisten für den Fachinstituten, die sich darauf natürlich stark konzentrieren. Und die das als Hauptaufgabe auch haben.
Aber wo fällt Raumfahrt jetzt beim DLR konkret? Also Software für Raumfahrt, wo, in welchen Bereichen des DLR findet das so statt aus deiner Perspektive?
Aus meinem Perspektiv ist das vor allem DLR Bremen, Institut für Raumfahrtsysteme zum Beispiel, zum Klasch Institute, die Raumfahrtsysteme entwickeln und entwerfen zum Beispiel. Und auch sowas wie echtzeitfähige Software machen. Da geht es dann zum Beispiel um die Betriebssysteme, die dann auf Satelliten oder anderen Systemen laufen. Und natürlich die Lageregelungssoftware zum Beispiel, die man ja immer braucht. Und überhaupt Software, die die ganzen Experimenten oder sowas steuert im Satelliten oder anderen System. Das ist schon sehr raumfahrtlastig.
Jetzt, euer Team setzt sich das im Wesentlichen aus Informatikern zusammen? Oder aus welchem Wissenspool verstärkt ihr vor allem so eure Mannschaft?
Heutzutage sind in unserer Gruppe hauptsächlich Informatiker. Das hat sich ein bisschen gewandelt. Als ich angefangen hab, waren das fast keine Informatiker da. Die meisten waren damals Mathematiker, weil wir auch viel Software entwickelt haben, die sehr mathematisch war, numerische Algorithmen. Also ich selbst bin ja auch Mathematiker eigentlich. Aber es hat sich gewandelt. Wir haben zunehmend in den letzten Jahren Informatiker gesucht und eingestellt. Aber es gibt auch bei uns durchaus noch Physiker zum Beispiel, die da sind oder wir haben Linguisten da oder jemanden, der auch Psychologie studiert hat, studiert hat eigentlich, aber dann jetzt im Nebenfach in einer Feiernachschule noch Informatik nachgeschoben hat. Und dann eben tatsächlich auch noch Mathematiker.
Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen der Bereich, wo man wirklich auch so vor allem einen hohen Bedarf an klassischen Informatikern hat. Also wo wirklich so die Kernausbildung, die man in der Informatik erfährt, viel mathematischer ist als jetzt, man das vielleicht häufig vermutet. Man denkt ja immer so, wenn man Programmierer werden will, dann muss man Informatik studieren. Ich denke, da schüttelst du genauso mit dem Kopf, wie ich das kennengelernt habe. Aber man lernt ja eben in der Informatik ein sehr viel übergreifenderes Wissen. Und das klang ja jetzt hier eben schon durch die vielen Ausführungen an. Strukturierung von Daten, Strukturierung von Projekten, Vorangehensweisen, Überprüfungsmethoden, Dokumentation etc., Anforderungsplanung. Das fällt ja da alles mit rein. Und in eurem Institut kommt das sozusagen auch geballt zum Einsatz. Das ist mal so ein Feld, das hat man ja auch nicht häufig. Wo sozusagen das Kernwissen der Informatik auch als solches Anwendung findet.
Ja genau. Also das ist in jedem Fall gefragt bei uns. Was bei uns von Vorteil ist, wenn man bei uns arbeitet, ist in jedem Fall aber Interesse auch für die anderen Themen des DLR. Also für die Ingenieurwissenschaften oder physikalischen Sachen. Weil wenn man bei uns arbeitet, sehr viel Kontakt mit den anderen Kollegen hat. Also gerade natürlich Beantwortungsanalyse ist das klar, aber auch in späteren Phasen, wenn man über die Software redet, die immer für einen speziellen Ingenieurwissenschaftlichen Einsatzzweck ist, dann wird es sehr schwer für einen persönlich mit den Leuten zu reden, wenn man gar kein Interesse hat und vielleicht auch nicht schon mal irgendwo die Schlagworte aus dem anderen Bereich gehört hat. Dann kommt es schon vor, dass man aneinander vorbei redet. Also jetzt so ein reiner Informatiker, der nur Software hacken will, es gibt Fälle von Leuten, die wir dann auch nicht auf andere Ingenieure loslassen zum Beispiel. Weil das auch nichts bringen würde. Die reden dann einfach aneinander vorbei. Also interessant sind Leute, die dann tatsächlich auch ein bisschen Interesse dafür haben oder offen sind für solche Ingenieurwissenschaftlichen Themen. Natürlich wollen wir ja auch nicht unbedingt nur diesen Raumfahrtfreak haben, der sich für Raumfahrt interessiert und dann zur Not auch ein bisschen programmiert und das dann auch nicht entsprechend kann, weil seine Interessen woanders liegen. Aber so Informatiker, die sich ein bisschen technisches Interesse haben, das sind eigentlich bei uns Idealkandidaten.
Ihr macht so ein bisschen auf mich so den Eindruck, als wärt ihr so ein bisschen dieses Schornstein-Feger. Die kommen dann so in unregelmäßigen Abständen vorbei, um so ein bisschen auszuputzen. Und sozusagen die Systeme wieder in Ordnung zu bringen. Das ist mir so ganz positiv, weil man freut sich ja immer, wenn der Schornstein-Feger kommt.
Im Bereich des reinen Software-Engineering ist das ein bisschen so. Da kommen tatsächlich mal Leute vorbei und sagen, wir haben eine Software entwickelt, die, wenn so ein Kollege dann sagt, habe ich früher als Student schon mal angefangen und jetzt bin ich zwar schon Abteilungsleiter, aber in jeder Generation nach mir, dann haben die Leute ein bisschen was dran geändert und eine neue Version erzeugt und einen Branch angelegt. Also es gibt am Ende vielleicht drei bis zehn verschiedene Varianten von der ursprünglichen Software. So und jetzt wollen wir aber wieder eine Software daraus machen. Hilfe, was machen wir jetzt? Und dann kommen die zu uns und dann sollen wir da irgendwie so Feuerwehr oder sowas spielen. Das kommt tatsächlich vor. Aber es gibt auch, natürlich ist das nicht unsere Hauptaufgabe und das machen wir auch nicht zum Hauptteil unserer Zeit. Also ist schon so, dass wir in den meisten Fällen auch bei der Neukonzeptierung von Anfang an mit irgendeiner Software dabei sind. Und manchmal eventuell die dann auch selber entwickeln oder zumindest das irgendwie begleiten, die Entwicklung. Also die Feuerreaktionen sind, sind Gott sei Dank nicht so häufig. Also es ist manchmal ganz interessant, weil das grundsätzlich ja, also in vielen Fällen lernen wir dadurch auch neue Gebiete des DLR kennen. Das ist einer der Vorteile, wenn man sozusagen bei einer Gruppe wie uns arbeitet. Ich glaube, wir kennen schon mehr aus dem DLR als normale wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter aus anderen Instituten.
Wo man einfach überall Einblick erhält.
Genau, wir haben in wirklich allen Bereichen Einblick, haben mit allen Bereichen irgendwie schon zu tun gehabt. Das geht dann von den klassischen Ingenieurdisziplinen wie Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik mit so was wie Strömungsimulation etc. Bis hin natürlich zu medizinischer Anwendung. Was viele Leute ja gar nicht wissen, dass der Medizinbereich im DLR auch so stark ist. Oder Ähnliches, also auch gerade Solarforschung und so weiter.
Läuft da nicht auch Gefahr, dann viele Mitarbeiter in diese anderen Bereiche zu verlieren, die dann irgendwann so ihre neue Liebe entdecken?
Gefahr ist ein interessantes Wort. Es ist natürlich teilweise eine Gefahr, aber andererseits auch eine gute Chance. Zum einen für Mitarbeiter bei uns, weil bei uns steigt man ja in der Regel im Zeitvertrag ein. Befristetem Vertrag. Viele Leute kommen auch bei uns als Studenten erst mal nur hin. Wir haben nicht genug Plätze, um alle eine feste Stelle anzubieten. Es ist eher eine große Chance, dass Leute bei uns Kontakte kriegen können zu anderen Instituten und dort dann eine feste Anstellung finden können.
Also bewusst als Inkubator, dass man da erstmal alles kennenlernt und schaut, wo kann ich mein informatisches Wissen in den einzelnen Forschungsbereichen vielleicht am besten einbringen bzw. was macht mir einfach am meisten Spaß, dass man dann auch ein konkretes Projekt kennenlernt und dann sieht man, wo man sonst vielleicht gar nicht mit in Berührung gekommen wäre.
Es gibt inzwischen eine ganze Reihe Leute im DLR, schön verteilt auf alle möglichen Standorte, die ursprünglich mal bei uns waren, als Mitarbeiter oder Studenten.
Und im Idealfall habt ihr dann auch so das Software Engineering verbessert.
Genau, die verbreiten das dann natürlich ein bisschen und haben natürlich auch dann sehr guten Kontakt. Also das ist auch für uns immer ganz gut, wenn wir dann auch mehr Einblicke dort jeweils haben. Aber gerade das Wissen, was die bei uns dann mitkriegen über Software Engineering, das hilft dann dort vor Ort natürlich auch stark und nimmt uns andererseits dann Arbeit ab. Klar, die Arbeit investieren wir quasi am Vorher, indem wir den Leuten das dann beibringen, quasi in der Einarbeitungsphase. Und dann können die das dann in den Instituten weitergeben.
Geht ihr denn auch mal so ein bisschen nach draußen auf andere Veranstaltungen und kündet von euren Tätigkeiten?
Wir als Softwareleute sozusagen. Machen wir in jedem Fall. Also natürlich sind wir auf ganz vielen Konferenzen vertreten. Es gibt natürlich den Bereich der wissenschaftlichen Konferenzen, wo wir Vorträge halten, wo auch eine schriftliche Veröffentlichung vorher geschrieben wird. Und was wir auch zunehmend machen, ist, wir sind auf sogenannten Community-Veranstaltungen mit Vorträgen oder mit Ständen oder so vertreten. Also Vorträge dieses Jahr auf solchen Sachen, wie zum Beispiel der Frostcon oder so Apachecon und solche Sachen. Das sind so Konferenzen, wo eigentlich fast jedes Jahr jemand von uns dabei ist. Eclipse-Konferenzen oder ähnliches.
Also wo auch viel Open Source im Mittelpunkt steht. Das heißt, den Kontakt hinsucht ihr auch bewusst?
Unmöglich, ja. Also es ist ja so ein, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel auf so eine Veranstaltung wie die Frostcon gehen, frei und Open Source-Community mit Menschen in Manisie, Mitte Augusta immerhin, St. Augustin bei Bonn. Da haben wir halt einen Stand, wo wir uns als DLR präsentieren und mit ganz verschiedenen Aspekten. Also wir sind natürlich da, um uns bekannt zu machen, dass wir überhaupt nur aus dem Software zu tun haben und Open Source, weil viele Leute das natürlich gar nicht wissen. Die sehen natürlich nur Luft- und Raumfahrt. Wir sind natürlich auf der Suche nach neuen Leuten bei sowas. Also neue Mitarbeiter als feste Mitarbeiter oder als Studenten für Abschlussarbeiten zum Beispiel. Und wir wollen auch natürlich Neues lernen und mit anderen Leuten einfach nur so diskutieren. Das ist natürlich ganz toll, wenn einer nicht nur kommt, weil er irgendwie einen Job sucht oder was er über Raumfahrt wissen will, sondern wenn er uns was Spannendes über irgendein Software erzählt, was dann auch sehr wertvoll für uns ist. Also auch gerade diese Diskussionen an solchen Veranstaltungen sind sehr wertvoll. Deswegen werden wir das auch in Zukunft in jedem Fall weiter betreiben und eventuell ausbauen.
Okay, Andreas, ich sag mal vielen Dank. Ich denke, jetzt haben wir hier einmal ganz gut abgesteckt. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, diese Dinge zu erfassen. Aber was, glaube ich, sehr gut klar geworden ist, ist, dass es so ein Kernelement gibt in diesem gesamten Forschungsgefüge, von dem eben so Softwareentwicklung quasi in die anderen Bereiche mit ausstrahlt und wo man eben auch potenziell auch mit einsteigen kann. Aber nicht nur, wenn man mit Open Source zu tun hat. Ja, vielen Dank. Und bis bald, bis zur nächsten Ausgabe von Raumzeit.